i just have to remind myself i was
playing the god of mischief
um which is a hell of a thing to be god
of actually you know
there's gods of war and thunder and
justice and and this guy was the god of
mischief so i i knew i had to have as
much fun as possible you know the devil
plays all the best tunes and kenneth's
been a bit of a mentor to you
guys yeah yeah we we've done a lot of
work together i mean uh
we started out um on the radio bbc radio
3
did a radio play of sereno de bergerac
and then we did
wallander on television and then we did
a check off play called ivanov actually
just around the corner
uh in the west end and and in that play
was when we really got to know each
other because
chekhov always dramatizes the um the
brilliant sort of
tussle between the old and the young and
ken was very much the old
bull and i was the young bull and he was
sort of full of doubt
and and shades of grey and the young
doctor was
black and white and full of certainty
and edge and there was a wonderful scene
where we basically
shouted at each other for about 10
minutes and that's when we kind of
really tested each other's mouths
basically yes the bbc's casting director
had sent me the script for wallinder and
i remember
embarrassingly and bashfully meeting
uh ken brana at the costume fitting and
he said so i'm calling this my
hiddleston year
and i just thought well don't [ __ ] it up
basically
mercifully i didn't um so
uh and then and then we became firm
friends and and um
and that was when he invited me to
audition for thor and it was a very open
net they were casting they both that
marvel wanted
young actors to play their principal
roles who had no previous attachment in
the audience's mind
and i got cast as loki and that was
really that was my foot in the door so
to speak
i just love that your connection with
brenna expands both
stage and radio and tv because of
wallender and then film it's like the
only thing you guys didn't do together
was like the telegraph that you're like
you know
you guys hit every every possible medium
we're very excited for thor
too um are you excited to get the girl
back on again
i've just finished yeah so i was doing
it for four or five months from
september to sort of mid-january
it was amazing how physical is that as a
role i mean there's an awful lot
it is physically it's more visible than
you'd think actually the hardest thing
is
because loki usually takes all the hits
like i just get hit a lot
by everybody by the hulk by thor by iron
man whoever it is
and actually to be fit enough to throw
yourself at the floor
or the wall or someone else's face is
you actually have to be like in fairly
decent shape so this is quite physical
but
it's a good time you know there's so
much padding uh there is enough padding
yeah just enough just sprouting up is
that story true about how you grabbed
the water bottle as a when you had heard
that uh branno was was directing thor
you went as to as your fake prop hammer
and went up there and said
you know think of me as thor is that
that's a true story you know
we live in a world that is ruled by the
marvel universe now
and and um there was a time when they'd
made one
film and it was iron man
and uh so we were all in
in during the theatrical run of ivanov
in the west end
um it was very exciting we were just as
a company we were very excited
on behalf of on his behalf that he had
managed to land this huge directing gig
which none of us knew about and um
somebody told me
um gina mckee who i had most of my
scenes with
was playing his wife and she told me
that ken had got this huge
directing gig and so as the czechovian
doctor in that play i had longer hair
and a goatee and
wire-rimmed spectacles and a pocket
watch and you know i looked like a
very slavic russian doctor from the 19th
century i
as a joke in the interval i picked up
this empty water cooler
and ran up to ken's dressing room and
pretended to be swinging thor's hammer
um it's probably ill-advised but i did
it anyway
um and um and then actually that was
when he said well actually don't joke
there's a couple of good parts in there
there has been i think some kind of
twitter battle going on um
between uh adam deacon and chris o'dowd
and myself i think i think eddie
redmayne and chris hemsworth
their taste is far too good uh to have
even twitter accounts they don't get
involved
they don't need to yeah
which might mean they're brighter stars
right whereas the rest of us on the
street are still
battling it out on twitter working it we
shouldn't i haven't campaigned of course
lockheed versus thor again tonight
in the same category and soon to be in
the avengers yeah
i love it because um you know we first
met actually at kenneth branagh's house
speaking of which here he is there he is
just behind you
we met at his house and uh i never met
him in my life before and he's a really
one
charming like great guy and we were both
we couldn't believe it
natalie portman was also there and while
ken was doing some work with natalie
ken said why don't you go off for a run
or something go and train together so we
went off
having known each other for an hour okay
and you know you sort of get chatting
and you're like
can you believe that this is happening
he's like no mate that is so
surreal yeah in exactly that voice well
we're very lucky that you didn't get
thor and you got loki because really it
i think that the key to so much of
whether it's richard the third or it's
any sort of
the villain needs to be somebody that is
playful and devious and you find
so many rich layers of nuance within
loki what was the key to him for you to
that character
um well uh
ken and i kind of used shakespearean
villains as a touchstone it was a very
it read like quite a shakespearean
script
and the journey of thor actually was
very similar to
the journey of prince howe in the henry
iv and henry the fifth trilogy
which obviously he knew very well having
played hal and henry the fifth many
times
and and so thor goes from a hot-headed
impetuous young prince into being a
um into being worthy of of his title
and similarly um we tried to think about
the um the immaculate
uh and terrifying
um talent for improvisation that's a
character like iago has
someone who can think on his feet and
manipulate every situation to his
advantage
we talked about cassius and julius
caesar
who is characterized as having a lean
and hungry look
we talked about the brothers in king
lear um edmund
and edgar edgar being the favored son of
gloucester and edmund being the bastard
son
who is driven by some sort of
terrible lack of self-esteem to to
take his father and his brother down um
so those seem to be interesting
aspects to to steal from shakespeare
really
um and then um
i just have to remind myself i was
playing the god of mischief
um which is a hell of a thing to be god
of actually
you know there's gods of war and thunder
and justice and
and this guy was the god of mischief so
i i knew i had to have as much fun as
possible you know the devil plays all
the best tunes
um and it became that became a cocktail
and then weirdly
from those beginnings he
[Music]
he just emerged he emerged in costume
fittings he emerged as i dyed my hair
black
and i
read the first script and i thought
there was a fascinating inside this
extraordinary lavish visual effects
you know action spectacular there's a
very
simple human drama about a father and
two sons
and it's one that that brown had talked
to us about to
anthony hopkins and chris hemsworth and
myself it was a real we really worked on
that
um that inside you know rainbow bridges
and
journeys through space and time that
there was actually something people
could latch onto that was human and real
the best villains don't think of
themselves as villains i mentioned
richard the third a couple minutes ago
he thinks he's doing the right thing you
know and in the marvel universe as well
it's the same type of dynamic
to them they're not the villain they're
the one who's just have a different
point of view and
the one that everybody should listen to
right every villain is a hero in his own
mind
and i really latched on to that you know
he's someone who's actually trying to do
the right thing he just makes
bad choices even in avengers he's still
trying to
make him make the right choice possible
exception of taking over the world
with his proto-fascistic tendency
you